[MUSIC PLAYING]
MODERATOR: We hear
next from Viki.
Fred has stimulated a
lot of recollections.
And I think I'll have to
curb myself from referring
to rattlesnakes in the desert.
There were a Bolivian revolution
encountered by that group,
on and on.
And the other thing
that comes to mind
is Zacharias once saying
that we have accelerators
like other people have mice.
And in any case, Viki
needs no introduction.
I only need note that he
was one of the prime people
Zach turned to to build
on what was already here.
And Viki responded with
his usual good measure.
I think Fred has
touched on much of it.
I don't need to repeat it.
So I simply turn to--
I think we know him as the never
cool and forever passionate
Viki.
[APPLAUSE]
WEISSKOPF: Now
let's install the--
let's see.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
WEISSKOPF: Is that OK?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
WEISSKOPF: You hear me.
Well, I am supposed to
talk about my life at LNS
in the framework
of the old days.
So that is perfectly correct,
since I belong to the old days.
It's, of course, very
difficult to speak of 46 years.
which I spend here, in 35
minutes, but I will try.
We'll see how far I come.
You see, I came, actually,
to this country 55 years ago.
First to Rochester, where I
got an offer as an instructor,
and then assistant professor.
And in '43, Oppenheimer asked
me to come to Los Alamos.
And all the time in
Rochester, my wife and I
wanted, actually, to come
to the Cambridge area,
where there is so much culture,
music, and everything, science,
and so many friends.
So we were very happy when at
the end of Los Alamos, where
we became so terribly famous
for making this terrible weaon,
that Zacharias came to
hire people for MIT.
Well, MIT is in Cambridge.
So I was very glad about this.
And I accepted right away.
Together, as you
know, he came there
to get a few people
who were here,
among others, Bruno Rossi,
Martin Deutsch, and Woodward,
and some others.
And we were supposed to start
here, the fundamental physics,
which was already here, but
perhaps not very active.
So it was a pleasure to
come here and begin, again,
to deal with physics, with
real physics, after what
we had to do in Los Alamos.
Now, Zacharias promised
an easy life here.
He spoke about LNS, that the
Laboratory of Nuclear Science
will be established, and will
help us in every respect.
Of it did.
And I must say, with a
certain pride and perhaps
a certain shame,
that in all my life,
I never wrote a request
for money to Washington,
because all this was done by
LNS, by [INAUDIBLE] and others.
So I just have told them
what I want, and I got it.
Now, I think that--
I'm not sure
whether it's unique.
But I think it is unique that to
spend a active scientific life
and never write a proposal.
And I will stick to it
to the end of my life.
Now
Now, I came 1946.
And of course, at that time,
at the beginning of 1946,
it was very difficult
to find housing here.
We had great trouble.
And my family, with
the small children,
had to live in Cape
Cod for half a year,
because the house wasn't ready.
But it was just great fun
to be really back again
in fundamental physics.
Nuclear physics, of course,
was also done in Los Alamos.
But field theory,
electrodynamics, and all this.
And to work with such
wonderful people.
First of all, Herman Feshbach.
I will talk about this later.
And the young staff here.
And the [INAUDIBLE] Fran
Friedman, who, unfortunately,
is no longer with us, John
Blatt, Amos [INAUDIBLE],,
and [? Amon ?] [? Darr, ?]
and some others.
And graduate students.
And I must say, I really had
excellent graduate students.
And I mention only a few.
Bruce French, Murray Gell-Man,
[? Claude ?] Gottfried,
Arthur [INAUDIBLE],, Dave
Peaslee, [? Carson ?] Wang,
and so on.
Now, back to physics.
Of course, physics
activities at that time
were interrupted
by sort of physics
and real politics, by
talks about the bomb,
and the desire of an
international committee
to deal with nuclear
affairs, to begin
with the Federation of
American Scientists,
and the Emergency Committee
Against Nuclear War
with Einstein, and all this.
So it wasn't only physics,
but it was mostly physics.
The beginning, of course, of
all that return to physics
was the Shelter Island
Conference in 1947
that Oppenheimer organized
and [INAUDIBLE] organized,
where we discussed
all the where we have
to get again into the work.
And that was, of course,
a sensational meeting,
because Lamb-Retherford
announced the measurement
of the Lamb shift at that time.
And let me just
tell you an anecdote
to describe the fame
of the physicists
at that time because of the
bomb that ended the war.
At the end of the
conference, Oppenheimer
had to go very quickly to
Cambridge, because that
was a time when Marshall,
General Marshall,
was supposed to announce
the Marshall Plan,
and [? Opie ?]
wanted to be there.
So he hired a plane, and invited
a few people, Bruno Rossi,
myself, and I think Herman,
also, Herman Fishbach,
to go with him in that plane.
And that was a little plane.
And the weather
became very nasty.
And in New London, the pilot
said, I don't know what to do,
because I should actually land.
It's too dangerous.
But on the other hand,
the airport in New London
is a military airport, and
I'm not allowed to land there.
And [? Opie ?] said to
him, well, do it anyway.
And you could already
see a surgeon there
with a red face cursing us
and giving a sign we are not
supposed to land.
And the poor pilot was unhappy.
And [? Opie ?] s said to
him, let me handle this.
And so we landed.
[? Opie ?] got out.
And here is this man cursing us.
And he said, I am
Dr. Oppenheimer.
And then this surgeon said,
are you the Oppenheimer?
And he said, I am a Oppenheimer.
And we are coming from
a nuclear conference.
So he was the Oppenheimer.
So right away, red carpet
was put on the floor.
We went right into breakfast
of the [INAUDIBLE] place.
And we were honored, and shipped
in a bus directly to Cambridge.
So you see, at that
time, nuclear physicists
had a certain pull.
Good.
Now, the Shelter Island
Conference, of course,
had an enormous
effect, and especially
on a part of my
physics activities,
namely together with
[INAUDIBLE] French,
we tried to calculate
the Lamb shift.
We even started before
the experiment was done.
But we didn't work very hard.
That's typical for a theorist
if there is no experiment.
Well, the theorist
of these times.
And with no
experiments [INAUDIBLE]
we didn't work very hard.
But when the experiment
was out, Bruce and I
worked day at night.
I should actually mention that
Hans [? Beatty ?] produced
in his usual quick
intelligence at Shelter Island
a semi-quantitative
theory of the effect,
Only the constants were
not quite determined yet.
And we calculated the whole
thing and got the right result.
And then came the
dark days of my life,
namely that we were
really the first ones who
had made that calculation,
but we showed it
to Schwinger and Feynman.
And Schwinger and
Feynman recalculated it,
and got a different result.
But both Schwinger and Feynman
got the same result. Under
these conditions, of course,
you have a difficult time.
Now, instead of sticking
to our calculations,
we should have done, we
recalculated, recalculated
until half a year later, I got
a telephone call from Feynman,
you are right and we are wrong.
And then we were not the first.
It was Lamb and [? Krall ?]
who did a similar calculation.
Well, you better
have self-confidence.
Now, so my interest at that time
and interest of the theoretical
group were very much
divided between fundamental
electrodynamics-- field
theory, in other words--
and nuclear physics.
And of course, after
our calculation,
which was a very
complicated one,
I got the idea actually
from [INAUDIBLE]
that what you should do,
calculate the self energy
of the free electron
[INAUDIBLE] since I
have calculated self energies
for a long time before.
And I should calculated the self
energy of the bound electron
in hydrogen, and then subtract.
But subtracting two
infinities is a difficult job.
And we did it in a sort of
clumsy, but correct way.
Then came-- all
this was, of course,
cleared up and made very
elegant by Schwinger, Feynman,
Tomonaga, Dyson, and so on.
So our calculation has
only historical interest.
But nuclear physics.
It was in some ways a
continuation of the work
I did in Los Alamos.
But I had several
great advantages.
First is, and I would
like to mention it again,
the wonderful support
from LNS that I don't need
to worry about money
and support and paying
assistants and post-graduate.
And the greatest
advantage of all
was to have met
Herman Feshbach here.
And then it began right
from the beginning
an extremely fruitful
collaboration
of two people, who, I
think at least personally,
are not so different.
But in their
approach to physics,
we were just different,
and just complementary,
a wonderful complementary.
I am more intuitive or,
shall we say, more sloppy,
hand-waving in my
way of doing physics.
He is more mathematical,
formalistic,
but still appreciates,
also, the general aspect.
And so we had a
wonderful team together.
Different approaches, but
not different characters.
It was a wonderful
mutual understanding
not only for physics, but of
all problems we meet, political.
There's a deep
friendship that lasted.
It still becomes
stronger every year,
in physics, in scientific
politics, in real politics,
and with our families.
So well, it is not
time enough to mention
what we did together, but a
clouded crystal ball model
was one of the important things,
which explained measurements
by [INAUDIBLE].
We're very proud
that our theories
did exactly the curve--
almost exactly the curves
that were measured.
But let me say, one of the more
important things of that time
was that the book, the book,
but it's the Blatt and Weisskopf
book.
I decided roughly
in the late '40s
that such a book
should be written.
There was only one
book available,
the so-called bible
of Hans [? Beatty ?]
and [INAUDIBLE] and others that
was published before the war.
So there was really a need for
a theoretical nuclear physics
book.
And I had, again, the luck of
finding a post-doc, John Blatt,
who came--
he made his PhD at
Cornell, who came,
and I asked him to work with me.
And that was, again, a
wonderful combination.
Now, I would like to
make sure that it is not
like the famous combination
of Landau and Lifshitz,
where people said that there
is no word written by Landau
and no idea conceived
by Lifshitz.
But that wasn't that way.
There were lots of
words written by Blatt.
And he contribute
a lot of ideas.
But he was a much
more accurate man.
He is a very good mathematician.
He didn't allow hand-waving
arguments and things
of this kind.
And also, he made me work.
I remember, once I came in
the morning and said to him,
yesterday I saw a very
interesting movie.
He said, you were at a movie?
You should have
written chapter 13.
And so he really kept me
working extremely hard.
And then there was an
interesting conflict
with [INAUDIBLE], the publisher.
Because I in him the manuscript.
Yeah, I always stick to the
alphabetical order, Blatt
and Weisskopf.
And the reason is
because my first paper,
which had some influence on
physics, was one with Wigner.
And I had the luck to find
a famous collaborator who
was in the alphabet after me.
So it was Weisskopf and Wigner.
And then I made a vow that
from now on, since my name was
the first one in that paper of
the natural line width, which
most of you know, that I
made a vow I I will always
publish in alphabetical order.
So I went to
[INAUDIBLE] and said,
this is Blatt and Weisskopf.
And [INAUDIBLE] said
that we cannot do this.
You are known.
You are the senior officer.
It must be Weisskopf and Blatt.
Then I fought with him.
I said I made a vow.
He said that it's
none of our concern.
We are concerned about
selling the book.
And then finally I convinced
him with the following argument.
When it is Weisskopf and Blatt,
the emphasis is on Blatt.
When it is Blatt and Weisskopf,
the emphasis is on Weisskopf.
[LAUGHTER]
And he bought that.
He bought that.
And finally, it was
Blatt and Weisskopf.
Well, I have made the
experience in writing
this book an experience
that I had later on also.
It is really wonderful
to write a book.
Well, it's not wonderful
It's a terrible work.
It always takes 10 times
more time than you think.
But it is wonderful
in the following way,
that you really have to
think about everything.
And therefore, you find,
in writing a book, themes
for original work.
That has to be worked out.
This has to be worked out.
And so it was also with that
that a lot of original papers
came from writing this book--
among others, the calculation of
gamma ray radiation, which is I
think the only place
where my name enters
into the language of physics
with the so-called Weisskopf
units; and other things, the
collaboration with Walecka,
who is, I hope, here, and
Gomes about nuclear matter.
And quite a lot of things
came out of writing that book.
And at the end, of
course, in some ways also,
the clouded crystal ball
work with Herman Feshbach,
and the compound nucleus
work with Francis Friedman,
the compound nucleus
and direct reactions,
things that later on
were really developed
into a systematic theory
of nuclear reactions
by Herman Feshbach.
Well, theory wasn't
completely neglected.
I tried to calculate
with [INAUDIBLE]
the magnetic moment of nucleons
that was pre-quark time.
And nowadays, it turns out that
with quarks, you can also not
explain it so easily.
But we did it differently,
which it's probably
not very important paper.
And then the
independent-particle model,
at that time, of
course it was a time
when the shell
model of the nucleus
was produced by
Jensen and Mayer.
And everybody was astonished how
[INAUDIBLE] nucleons run almost
like independent
particles in the nucleus
although the interaction
is so strong.
And well, we tried
to think about this
and wrote a few papers about
how this really comes about.
Out of this came also
the collaboration
with [INAUDIBLE] and
Walecka and Gomes.
And then the bag model, the
bag model, the famous MIT bag
model, was of course one of
the triumphs of this place
of the theoretical division.
And well, I didn't
contribute much.
I encouraged people
like Johnson,
like Ken Johnson and Bob
Jaffe and others to go ahead.
I found it extremely
interesting.
I completed a few
hand-waving, as
usual, hand-waving arguments.
But well, they put
my name on the paper.
I'm very glad they did it,
but I'm not sure I deserve it.
By the way, I would like
to show this picture, which
shows sort of the
MIT collaboration
in theoretical physics.
You see here-- well,
this is John Blatt.
That is Bruce French.
That's Herman,
and that's me when
I was still young and black.
So this sort of
symbolizes the way we
worked and had a
wonderful time together.
Well, now let me say a few
words about other activities
which are more of social,
educational significance.
I tried to introduce a
few things that were fun
but didn't really
develop too much.
First, in the '50s, I had
the graduate student dinner.
We went out once
a month, I think--
was it a week?
No, once a month, I
think, or more frequent--
to have dinner together downtown
with the graduate students,
with some of the graduate
students in theory.
And they were
really very helpful.
It was wonderful.
We discussed, of course, mainly
physics, but not only physics,
also politics and general
questions, personal questions.
You know, it's very interesting.
The relation with the gradate
students has sort of changed,
but that is not only due to
the changes in our society,
but also due to age.
The difference in age becomes
bigger between gradate students
and me.
For example, in
Rochester, I was almost
the same age as the graduate
students at the beginning here.
Therefore they came to
me also with problems,
should I marry this girl or
not, in which case I always say,
if you ask, the answer is no.
But of course, now this
is no longer that way.
First of all, well,
I don't want to go
into the social, and some
aspects of our society,
but the whole-- this problem has
changed, too, not only physics.
Then I tried to do something
which I found very useful,
but then it was too hard on me--
namely, the colloquium question.
It turned out that the
graduate students did not come.
Only a few came
to the colloquium.
And then I said that's
very bad because it's
sort of instructive.
But I know the reason, because
the speakers are usually not
very good in the colloquium.
And then I tried to
do the following.
I said the so-called
pre-colloquium.
On Thursday at 2 o'clock, I
invited the graduate students
to come, and I will
tell them what I think
the speaker is going to say.
Now, that's sometimes very
difficult. First of all,
I only know the title.
Sometimes, of course,
I know more about it.
But sometimes, I
have to guess and I
told them things
that may be very
interesting for the
graduate students
but had nothing to do
with the colloquium.
And sometimes, it was useful.
And indeed, I think
it has helped that--
it helped me
enormously because I
had to think about what
the title may mean.
And since I am always
against specialization,
I think one ought
to have at least
a scientific American
idea of all physics,
not only one specialty.
In other words, I
prefer to know--
instead of knowing
everything about nothing,
I prefer to know nothing
about everything.
And this was always
my fun in life.
And then I had also a seminar,
how to give a lecture.
And there were not
more than 12 people,
and they had to
choose a subject,
and preferably not
their own thesis subject
but another subject.
And then they had to
give a talk for one hour.
And the second hour of the
seminar, we criticized him.
You didn't explain this.
You didn't explain that.
You assumed that everybody
knows the foundations, which
is always a mistake, not only
of young speakers but also
of older physicists.
And so that was fun, but it
also somehow lasted a few years,
and it didn't--
not longer.
Well, then of course a very
important event in my life
was--
I have still a few minutes--
was 1960 when the
director of CERN, Bakker,
died in an airplane accident.
And the moment I
heard this, I thought
that means something in my
life because I was always
following very
closely what happens
in Europe, European physics.
And I tried also
to help with advice
and spend my sabbaticals over
there since somehow, I find
physics must be international.
And that's one reason.
And European physics, after
all, has really created physics.
And somehow, the ravages
of war were terrible,
and we have to help them.
And I also felt a
feeling of, how shall I
say, of I owe Europe so
much, the whole culture,
my education.
In spite of the terrible
things that happened there,
it is in Europe where many
of my cultural roots lie.
And I felt I would like to
pay back some of this debt.
And when I then was asked
to become director-general,
I accepted mainly
because of that reason,
but also because I never
had an administrative job
except that I was mayor
of Los Alamos, which
is sort of a ridiculous job.
But I was elected,
elected, mayor
of Los Alamos for two
years, which is great fun,
but that doesn't come here.
You can read it in
my autobiography.
And another reason, which I
never admitted, of course,
was that I loved skiing.
And of course, Geneva
is a wonderful center
for skiing over the weekends.
But I never admitted
that reason,
and God punished me for this
because I had a bad automobile
accident just when I started
becoming director so that I
had two years, no skiing.
Well, but anyway, it was for
me a tremendous experience,
not only from the
political point of view
that it's the first
international institution that
is not only paper shuffling
like the many UN organizations,
but where real work gets done
on an international basis
where the European
nations work together,
and also a lot of Americans.
And that was really, for
me, an enormous experience,
almost or perhaps
even more important
than the Los Alamos
experience, of creating
an international spirit.
And it was the first
year where the machines
were working, where research
has to be organized.
It was just a great thing.
And I must say, I enjoyed every
minute of my directorship,
though I had many
difficult problems.
But actually, the
collaboration was no problem.
Once, a journalist came
to me and asked me,
is it not very hard
to have Britishes
and French and Germans and
Italians working together?
I said, that is not hard at all.
What is hard is to have
two Italians work together.
And that was just after having
discussion with [INAUDIBLE]..
Well, when I came back, I didn't
want to spend my life at CERN.
Maybe I should have stayed a
little longer because tradition
of five years has
been kept and I
think it's a little too
short for a director-general.
But I came back after all, my
children and friends and so on,
and I don't want to live
all the time over there.
I came back as sort
of a different person,
in a way, because I had this
administrative experience.
So they asked me after a year to
become the head of department,
of physics department,
which I accepted.
But you see, I was a little
different from the other heads
because I have-- at CERN, there
was so many very good people
with experience who took
over the job of the financing
and the, you know--
in other words, I could
delegate authority and really
think about the
important things.
And I tried to do this also
in the department, where
it's much more difficult
because the department is
much more varied than
a laboratory like CERN.
But again, I ascribe it in
some ways to my laziness.
I don't want to go into
details of the finances.
I leave this to others.
And I had good helpers.
Pete Gold, so many of you
remember, [INAUDIBLE],, and then
Tony French, who
were my right-hands.
And so I really could do it.
And at that time, things were
not so bad as they are now.
I mean, it was much
easier to get money.
Indeed at that
time, basic science
was very well supported
by Washington.
And that's why it was possible
to hire very good people,
especially in theory.
We had [INAUDIBLE],, who is
here, fortunately, as our guest,
and then [INAUDIBLE]
and Steve Weinberg.
And so we had really
a wonderful addition,
and it was a pleasure, in a
way, to be head of department,
although it does cut--
as all my colleagues who were
head of department can admit,
it cuts into your physics time,
maybe not with Herman Feshbach
because Herman Feshbach
works 48 hours a day,
and then he has
time for physics.
Well, I'm now coming to the
time where I was getting old.
I got "retired," under
quotation marks, in '74.
And since then, my
activities sort of decreased.
But still, it is--
well, I was able to write
books, my autobiography
and other books and a
book with Kurt Gottfried
under concepts of particle
physics, which was not
the most stolen
book of the library
as Blatt and Weisskopf was.
And I'm not sure whether it
still is, but I don't think so.
But then, you know,
when you get old,
it is a little
harder to do physics
and to understand
physics, what's going on.
But I would call myself not
to be a passive physicist.
I like to hear.
And there are wonderful friends
who always have the patience
to come to my office
to explain in detail
and who don't mind
my stupid questions.
Maybe sometimes
they enjoy it, even.
I've had a number of people,
like Bob Jaffe and Johnson
and [INAUDIBLE] and many
others, who tell me what's going
on, and the experimenters--
I mean Henry Kendall
and Francis Friedman--
and tell me what's going on.
And I enjoy this.
And then also in other
fields, in solid state,
like Kastner and
[? Berger ?] now--
and he [INAUDIBLE].
And so it was a pleasure
to listen to physics.
And it's still my pleasure
to listen to physics
because physics is
still terribly exciting.
But of course, when
you're getting old,
you also want to do some things
which you always postponed--
interested in other things, do
more music, do more reading,
do more travel.
But still, I find I
am still trying to be
a member of this community.
And every time I come-- and
I come less frequent than
before--
I feel these are friends
and here's my home.
And of course, I made two
physical observations,
experimental observations.
One is that time runs
now faster than before.
Now, whether that's physics
or not, I don't know.
And also, gravity
becomes stronger,
because it's much
harder for me to go up
the stairs than before.
Well, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]